do you have tips on writing dialogue
where it doesn't sound
forced or even omitting dialogue i think
the only way to do that
is to watch movies and read scripts with
good dialogue
um have good conversations
um that's a tough one i don't know
you just know when it's not right uh for
me
like some of the masters like a
tarantino like
they approach it like a novel i think
more like a book
i think a lot of it has to do with
what's not said
um if you if you have clear if you have
a clear understanding of the
relationships between the characters
the dialogue comes off more naturally in
between those two
so i think you have to start there you
know if you know your characters
they start to talk to each other on
their own in a weird way
uh that's never been an issue for me
like my issue is i write too much
dialogue like my first film was like
they just said look man this is a
10-page scene and they're just talking
and i'm like well i don't know how to
cut it because i love everything they're
saying and i'm like
that's what they say he's like well we
can cut it now and cut it in the editing
room and i thought
well let's just do that we can cut it in
the editing room if it's not working
but um it was a challenge you know for
my actors to do a six-page scene
you know in six pages of dialogue
because i'm someone that likes to keep
the camera on them
and have them go through it i'm not
gonna break it up i want them to be
emotionally connected
and my stuff has a rhythm to it so if
they're not on that
that train they're gonna have a hard
time
you know but uh my dialogue is what
attracted a lot of actors to it i've
just they always you know whenever i
hear an actor say
um when they come when they say the
writing's so good they didn't have to
work as hard
that means they didn't have to sell it
they just had to speak it
you know you ever read titanic the
scripted titanic is really bad
it's like if you read it and that was
the only thing that didn't get nominated
for an academy award
ironically was the script but when you
read it
i mean the story is there the
relationships are there i'm just talking
about the dialogue
but leonardo dicaprio and kate winslet
are so skilled that when they say the
lines
you just believe it you know i'm sorry i
just
i don't think i'm the only one that said
that about titanic's script
and i'm not talking story structure i'm
not talking about anything i'm just
talking about the dialogue of that
you know um but if you have good enough
actors it doesn't matter like
they can sell it that's what they get
paid for right but um
whenever i hear an actor say yeah i
didn't have to work as hard on this one
that means that it was right there
you know and with my dialogue they have
to pick it up fast because
i'm shooting a feature in three weeks
you know so
you have a maximum of five takes
you know yeah is that what you meant by
a rhythm
because yeah okay yeah and um
you know if i have to camp i have more
than one camera and a couple occasions i
did then it's great
then then i have this thing going back
in this tennis match going back
and forth between the characters but um
in terms of tips that's a tough one i
think just
know who know who your characters are
before you start your screenplay
and it's weird but they start talking to
each other
it's very strange but that's that's been
my experience
it's like wait wait a minute how the
hell like and i'm shocked by it every
time i write a script
so that's the first thing it's like oh
my god how am i going to do this and
then you just start
getting into a flow and it just takes
practice right the more you do it
the better you're going to get at it you
know but don't give away plot in your
dialogue
we don't you know we don't talk like
that right
we don't talk about plot in life you
know
so you shouldn't you sh that should be a
first sign that the dialogue's bad
have you had actors on set and you
realize that it's way more effective for
them to say nothing
and you decide in the moment to take it
out yeah oh absolutely
because i've i come from silent movies i
also did a short film series
uh called the misadventures of trollo
chaplin and they were silent short films
black and white silent short films where
there was no dialogue
and in my seventh feature film there was
very little dialogue it was
all the actor so there was a lot of
that's sort of my background is now to
to give
less and tell more between the
characters through action and emotion
and less through dialogue
um that's more my just that's kind of
where i'm leaning right now
and not be so in love with my words that
well can we show that without them
saying anything
or saying a lot lot less yes always cut
the fat like cut as much as you
can you know the the simpler it is the
the the fuller it can be in a weird way
do you see that from being a beginning
filmmaker all the way until now
that really a lot of it was about
cutting the fat in someone
in some sense yes because my process
started
you know when i first wrote my first
screenplay that
it was i didn't have notes or anything i
just had an idea
right and so i would just start and then
at the end of that process you just have
this like
really fatty piece of meat
and then you realize i don't need this i
don't need that i don't need this or you
repeat yourself
you know now i'm i'm a more disciplined
a writer in a sense i'll write a
treatment first
so i don't have as much fat once my
script is done
because i already know what i'm not
going to use
because i've already done notes i've
done a treatment for it and now i'm
going to script form
and that's only been like the last two
or three scripts that i've written
you know so um i'm constantly learning
because i didn't start from some place
of
filmmaking you know
you